here to talk about all of this is our
friend from good morning football and he
also dabbles with fox sports as well our
friend peter schrager is back here on
the show how are you peter
hey rich i'm doing great happy monday
happy monday to you what's
the deal with the deshaun watson trade
as you know it as we're all sitting here
right now
on this uh this week seven monday what
do you have for me all right so deshawn
deshawn watson still has not been
suspended there still has not been put
on the exempt list i can assure you that
the nfl's league office has been
investigating this inside and out and
short of any uh new
whistleblower or anything new
evidence-wise i don't think he's going
to be suspended in the next
eight days
not gonna be put on the exemption list
in the next eight days meaning
technically if he was traded tomorrow
he could play on sunday the question is
is there a team that has the appetite to
take on the unknown so
miami has long been the rumored team not
because of houston's desire to trade him
there not because of miami
sending out leaks uh to the media saying
as much they've been the long
rumored team because apparently watson
has a no trade clause and that is a
destination that he would look fondly
upon carolina was thrown into the mix
yesterday i believe mike florio and nbc
sports was the first to put it out there
i think jay glazer mentioned it as well
and now we're going to follow suit and
say we've heard rumors of that but that
goes all the way back
before the
22 civil lawsuits that carolina was in
the mix
i just don't know if any team
any team at all rich has the appetite to
take this on
knowing what that comes with pr wise
what that comes with
morally without this thing being a
closed case and knowing that there could
be
some actual cases that
work themselves out in courtrooms in the
coming months i don't know if he is a
tradable player even if the the ask from
houston which originally i could confirm
was three first round picks and three
additional assets has lessened as we
inch closer to the trade deadline on
tuesday yeah it's just there's too much
risk there's way too much risk i mean
for you to then buy
the the off-season material and that's
now in your lap i i that's the thing
that kind of surprises me uh that there
is so much there there in being
discussed
you know um but the dolphins might be
desperate they're a one-win team
and they might have already evaluated
two over 11 games or whatever how many
starts it is and say this is definitely
not the guy oops
you know and they're they're trying to
fix that i maybe that's it maybe
desperation will outweigh the risks
peter yeah
and they don't have a first round pick
this year so they're one of the worst
teams in the league but when they traded
up from 12 to six they gave the eagles
their first round pick
um that that right there is is making it
even more interesting that hey if we can
get watson we're not going to get one of
the top picks in the draft we might as
well go and do this i think
another piece to this and this comes
from a team that does not need a
quarterback it comes from a gm that i
really respect and bounce a lot ideas
off of
so do you make a watson deal now
with all this unknown looming in an off
season
where rogers and wilson could be had for
maybe a similar amount of picks or maybe
even less
due to their age or whatever it is and
maybe their desire for destiny like
miami and carolina and denver those are
historically good markets with good fan
bases and places you want to play this
isn't like going to some place where
they don't win every 20 years these are
good teams and good organizations if
those are the three suitors for watson
do those teams just hang on tight
get to the off season and then make a
real push for aaron rodgers russell
wilson or if you're philadelphia do you
package all those pics together and do
something in the draft like whatever it
is
um this might not be the ideal crop of
off-season college quarterbacks but if
you're talking veteran quarterbacks that
could be on the market watson might not
even be in the top three come march
peter schrager here on the rich eisen
show what's the scene in san francisco
like right now is there really a hot
seat for kyle shanahan in san francisco
peter i don't think there's a hot seat i
will tell you that it is a tense
situation that's the word i would use
um the last year was kind of written off
because of the injuries fan base very
demanding doesn't want to hear it and
then
you look at what they gave up to get
trey lance if they had sat at 12 which
was their original pick before they did
all the maneuvering and traded up
mac jones might have been sitting there
and they would have two first round
picks the next two years now this is a
a 2020 hindsight thing that we can do
and we can play monday morning
quarterback after the draft but remember
that that friday morning after the draft
everyone was patting him on the back for
being so aggressive and go and get trey
land that said anyone who has realistic
expectations for a kid who played 17
games in college at that level knew that
he wasn't going to come in and
immediately be the starting quarterback
and take this team by storm so i think
patience has to be that they preach but
two and four is unacceptable for a team
that was in the super bowl two years ago
and there have been so many expectations
for this team to bounce back now that
players got healthy um their corners
last night rich were
drake kirkpatrick and josh norman who
have had very good nfl careers and will
a very good luck
for that to be the cornerback situation
and see michael pittman jumping all over
them and and having that success that
carson went did on that defense which
was supposed to be the hallmark of this
unit went a long way i think alan chris
hit it really good
um when they went deep into the deforest
buckner situation and michelle tafoya
had what was to me an explosive quote
buckner was shocked that they traded him
because they had armstead buckner and
bosa that could have gotten you a few
wins in herself they traded away buckner
and buckner's team got the better of
them there's a lot of frustration
amongst the fan base because outside of
that super bowl year
uh kyle shanahan has a losing record and
even with that super bowl here there
have been a lot of excuses made um but
not a lot of
uh actual big wins outside of that one
campaign so who's building the roster
there is it him i mean does he have does
he have that sort of control
within the the organization
in san francisco i think
i think obviously john lynch is the
general manager and
marathi is going to handle the shout out
so for kyle shane has got a very
influential voice and when it comes to
quarterback
that's shanahan's pick right there trey
lance now i know john
loved meeting with with lance up in
north dakota and they were they were on
the same page on that but after doing
all that work it was going to be in kyle
shanahan's hand
as far as whether it was matt jones
whether it was him whether it was justin
field in the draft i would also add that
last year's first round pick brandon
ayuk after the draft kyle shanahan came
out and said that they had iuk number
one on their draft board in a draft that
had justin jefferson and jaylen rhaegar
and henry ruggs and
judy and he was like no no this is our
guy we wanted you guys has been
invisible yesterday if it wasn't for
uh you know the punt being fortunately a
touch back that might have been one of
the biggest mistakes of the game last
night so when you look at those picks
ayuk and lance and trey sermon who i
think gotten going i would think that
kyle shanahan is a very very large voice
in the room as far as offensive players
taken in those early rounds yeah and
that's that's that i think is the mix
here peter that's got a lot of people
wondering if there's a hot seat i don't
think there is i don't think there's an
appetite by management to to bounce him
uh or even think about bouncing him or
go in a direction of bouncing him
because he would just bounce to another
spot
and plus they're only one game out of
the playoffs as they're currently
sitting right now in the longest regular
season ever but the question is that it
is a remarkable development that here
they had
the position and even shanahan mentioned
it and and was kind of uh you know
touting it that they had a veteran that
the locker room loved that took the team
to the super bowl a couple of years ago
so they had the cover of drafting
somebody this high and letting him
develop while sprinkling him in and now
we're in the position of how how fast
can he get back because jimmy g is not
the guy moving forward for a two and
four team that we're wondering about
player development right ayuka is
totally regressed like we're wondering
like is this the guy to develop anybody
or what is his
what is his um you know mindset in
developing players that's the question
right now um
i can't believe we're in that position
to be very honest with you
it's a conundrum because they also like
i mentioned uh you know when you have
josh norman as your number one corner on
the other side of the ball you're an
aging unit that hasn't necessarily
filled into the defensive backfield in a
in a problem area for this team for
quite some time um
i i find it interesting because we we
throw around the genius label with
mcveigh we throw on the genius label
with shanahan
there are some old school coaches and
old school defensive coordinators around
the league who love nothing more than
seeing these young offensive geniuses
quote unquote be humbled and be be in
the in the crux of it and right now i
think a lot of people
are taking a lot of not joy but there's
some snickering going on with okay
well everyone thinks kyle shanahan is
such a genius and all that and you guys
in the media and they point to me a lot
of time you guys in the media you crown
these young offensive wiz kids but gosh
doesn't look like they're so smart at
the moment so
you know there's going to be a great
what if and it's what if and we'll know
five years from now if true lance is
great or not but like what if they just
sat pretty and and if they took matt
jones or what if they traded up to the
three pick or the four pick with what
they did this year um and they took a
kyle pitt so they took uh to mark chase
so they took a different player than
having to trade all that draft capital
the 12th pick the and two more first
round picks for trey lance who might not
even be better than matt jones who would
have been sitting there peter schrager
of good morning football nfl network fox
sports so much more right here on the
rich eisen show what's the chiefs out
where where do they go from here because
you know you mentioned there are some
other coaches old school coaches around
the league are like ah we love uh
showing that the emperors and the the
offensive guru emperors have no clothes
on in san francisco etc uh but andy reid
is an old school guy and now this
offense can't move the ball worth the
lick can't hold onto it and definitely
can't stop it
so what's the chiefs out from here on
out yesterday yesterday looked really
alarming rich because they really did
not look like they had any juice or any
mojo i think
if you watch the nfl as close as you and
i do and we live and breathe it and we
love it so much even if you're not a
chiefs fan there's this feeling of
excitement when they're on the
television when it goes to them on the
red zone you know that there's going to
be something special it hasn't been
there and that that juice seems to be
gone and i think that's my question is
was that a a fleeting thing that we just
assumed would be here for a decade and
is that in our rearview mirror right now
mahomes obviously is struggling but the
entire team is struggling and there
doesn't seem to be that same pizzazz
doesn't seem to be that same energy and
uh you know the titans all credit goes
to them but i'm not sure that she's for
beating any teams with the way they were
playing yesterday and for the first time
uh in in my time covering the game and
that's probably 15 years as close people
are wondering okay well what's andy
doing monday to friday with this team
because they're coming out flat week
after week after week so
i think the buccaneers
smack them in the mouth in that super
bowl and i think a lot of people just
assumed they would lick their wounds but
rich we've been around the game too long
and it happens too often that super bowl
hangover it could be real and sometimes
these teams just don't snap out of it
seattle i'm still waiting for them to
get back to the super bowl after that
shocking loss to the patriots when i
think a lot of us thought that the
seahawks would be with in the in the
super bowl for for the next decade it
hasn't happened so not to be too
dramatic after seven weeks and what you
call the longest rail season ever which
it is but i don't know there's not a lot
of easy wins on that on that schedule
coming up after the giants game it gets
even harder for the chiefs and i'm not
sure this is going to be such a
no-brainer that we'll see them in
january so much to talk about here with
you peter schrager so a few more minutes
left with you let's let's talk about um
a team that is surprising everyone right
now um
and an offensive guru
um at the head coach the cincinnati
bengals how for real is this team do you
think
peter i think very very real um yeah
they beat the texans but they beat the
texans like 26 points and that game was
really
a runaway once they got the lead i love
um what steve time did this offseason
the general manager and that he very
deliberately saw a need for this team
and i spoke with him at lance over the
off-season and i kind of came at it with
a cynical view and maybe i shouldn't
have i'm like jj watt
aj green like is this retirement
community or what is this and we spoke
uh in august when i went there for our
back to football um stuff for the nfl
network and kyme was like no we looked
at each room and we thought can we get a
little better here if a little better
there but also who's the leader in the
locker room who's the leader in that
position group so you go up and down the
roster i think you know kyle is having
its mvp here i don't think it's any
coincidence that colt mccoy was at it
and has been a real good voice and
sounding board for him matt prater's the
kicker now they used to lose sleep over
who was going to kick field goals and
whether they were gonna be able to hang
on in the end trader's a veteran you go
right down that list rich and it's it's
jj watt it's chandler jones it's rodney
hudson it's aj green these are guys who
have done it in the league and yes kyler
is going to get the headlines and
deandre hopkins is going to be special
he always is but they are built as a
team top to bottom with young stars
bookended by veteran talent and that was
very deliberate by the front office
kingsbury is doing a nice job and kylo
is having an mvp candidacy but what they
did this off season to add those those
voices that are really replacing
um larry fitzgerald's voice which was so
omnipresent for the last 16 years i
think that is there's a testament to
that with how you build a roster and hey
when this happens when this goes wrong
who is going to be that veteran voice
that will lend um some wisdom and some
i've been there before
jj watt and aj green have been really
good players too it's not just what they
do uh in the room and the position
groups it's all been working out and
until kyler gets hurt and i knock on
wood 100 times they're going to be alive
and they're going to be as good as
they've been all season long i believe
you i'm i'm with you i mean again uh uh
jj watt and aj green and are in
positions of of not having to be the man
after they were the man in their usual
spot zack arts in his first game runs
one in uh i i feel like we're in one of
those cell phone commercials where maybe
i i i cut out i said bengals not
cardinals how for real are the bengals
it's all good
i'm an offensive guru i know that so but
you know so so as so as a bengals head
coach you know so uh how for real are
the bengals
peter should we take two can we try that
again it's all good it's all good it's
all good oh sure yeah some egg on my
face no
it's all good they came in they came
into that that uh that game they say cbs
um interesting 17 of the country got a
you know four in one bengals team versus
a four or one whatever the records were
it's only 17 percent i think that those
that kind of give you a litmus test on
what the country was thinking about the
bengals beforehand
most the country got um chiefs tightened
nationally and i don't think we're ever
going to deal with that again this
season with the bengals they're really
fun they're really good and that game
was up in the air in the second half
they went into a place where they've
been really bad the last few years lamar
obviously has never lost to the bengals
we talked about that all week long and
they smacked them around
they smack them around they put up 520
yards of offense in baltimore in the
bank where they don't lose the ravens
very rarely lose regular season games
there um i think that was a testament to
them but also a kind of coming out party
for the bengals as a team on a national
level saying no more you know give us
the third crew on cbs give us that
number one crew we're worthy of it and
if not that give us the number two crew
i think that stuff still matters it
still gives you a chance to see what
kind of the networks in the league
thinks of these teams
um we might not get many prime time
games from the bengals but i do think
we're going to start seeing iron eagle
and charles davis and maybe even jim
mance and tony romo calling those games
yeah not next week not next week because
they're at the jets um and that's the
way i want to finish i'm serious so
what's the deal with zach wilson
anything first blush there in new york
city that you're hearing about yeah not
good it's gonna be a couple weeks i
think and i'm not a doctor but uh that
m.c islander is real and you know the
jets went ahead and they threw them to
the wolves this season and he's eating
it and he is eating it and yesterday
matt judon got to him and you know i i
see a team like arizona and they've got
colt mccoy as the backup and i see a
team
uh like the patriots and they've got
veteran backups you know the jets they
turn to mike white
i know i i don't know either there's
there's no other way to put it other
than i don't know like what what are you
thinking
but i just i have a friend rich who die
our jets thing go saw the home game sure
but before the season
you know bought tickets to this one was
like this might be a down year for the
patriots drove up there drove up there
yesterday and it's not like he's some
hero but there are jets fans who are
still going to road games and it's like
at some point it's like these guys
that's a different generation like this
next generation of jets fans like guys
your son's age and and kids a little bit
older like there might not be a
generation of jets fans if they continue
to put this kind of product out there
every single week because it goes from
being like oh we're the lovable losers
to just like you know what i got other
things to do on sunday then then watch
my team lose 53 to 14.
great stuff as always peter thanks for
the time we'll see on good morning
football let's do this again real soon
thanks
that's brother schrager
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here